Headshot parents, if you didn't notice it in the title, our topic today is book the jobs that bleep you just heard, it won't be in the rest of the episode. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. Many of us at some point in our careers have had jobs that seem pointless. I once had a bullshit job working as a work study student when I was in college. I passed out flyers for the street car during one summer. I could not figure out why I was doing it.
各位听众，如果你们刚才没有注意到标题，我们今天的话题是那些哔——的职业。接下来的节目里不会再有这个词了。这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。在我们职业生涯的某个阶段，许多人都做过那些看似毫无意义的工作。我在上大学时，曾做过一份工读生的“狗屁工作”。有一个夏天，我一直在发有轨电车的传单。我完全搞不懂自己为什么要这么做。
I've had some temp jobs where I've literally sat in the closet. Jobs where you ask yourself, what am I even doing here? Like really, what is my actual role at this company? If I disappear tomorrow, would anyone notice? I was doing some paper filing, but they didn't have that much paper filing and for a week I sat in a supply closet. Doing expense reports and creating a new piece of paper for every single transaction item
我做过一些临时工，字面意思就是坐在壁橱里。在那种工作里，你会问自己：我在这儿到底在干什么？说真的，我在这家公司的实际角色是什么？如果我明天消失了，会有人注意到吗？我当时在做一些纸质文件归档，但他们根本没有那么多纸质文件要归档，于是在一个星期里，我都坐在杂货间里。处理费用报销单，为每一笔报销收据上的每一个交易明细
on every receipt for every single thing that expense like down to like the most minimal thing. This week we're looking at jobs that feel so pointless, so gut wrenchingly boring, that they are in the words of one expert, Bulschen. If you don't have one of these jobs yourself, you probably know someone who does. Like the guy binging YouTube videos on his computer at work, or the woman who always seems to be playing solitaire. So it was almost all office workers, almost all people who had jobs where, you know,
单独打印一张纸，哪怕是最微不足道的东西也不放过。本周，我们关注的是那些感觉极其无意义、极其无聊到让人反胃的工作。用某位专家的的话来说，这就是“狗屁工作”。如果你自己没有这种工作，你大概也认识这样的人。比如那个在上班时用电脑疯狂刷 YouTube 视频的家伙，或者那个似乎总是在玩纸牌游戏的女人。所以几乎所有的办公室职员，几乎所有那些你看着他们坐在那里，然后心里犯嘀咕的人，
you kind of see them there and you kind of wonder, is that kind of really doing anything? Well, it turns out, you know, they're not. Why do these jobs exist? Why do they seem to be proliferating? And what effects do these jobs have on us? The American TV show The Office tells the story of a paper supply company in Pennsylvania. People show up at work, but it's not always clear what they're doing.
你会想，这人真的在干什么吗？好吧，事实证明，他们确实什么都没干。为什么会有这些工作？为什么这些工作似乎在激增？这些工作对我们有什么影响？美国电视剧《办公室》讲述了宾夕法尼亚州一家纸品供应公司的故事。人们按时上班，但他们具体在干什么并不总是那么清楚。
A lot of the time, people invent pranks or distractions. You put my stuff in jello again. They're bored. Many of them want to find meaning in their work, but what they are doing is pointless. You want me to write down people's indefinable qualities. I want you to write down everything that people are doing all day and then type it up in a way that is helpful. Michael Scott, the boss played by Steve Corral, leads the way. I don't want to work. I just want to bang down this bungalow today. Did you ask me here for any specific reason? the way. David Graber has spent quite a bit of time thinking about the many, many real-life
很多时候，人们会想出恶作剧或各种消遣来打发时间。你又把我的东西放进果冻里了。他们感到无聊。他们中的许多人想在工作中找到意义，但他们所做的事情却毫无意义。你让我写下人们那些无法定义的特质。我希望你写下每个人一整天都在做的事情，然后把它整理成一份有用的报告。由史蒂夫·卡瑞尔饰演的老板迈克尔·斯科特带头这样做。我不想工作。我今天只想把这间平房砸了。你叫我来这里有什么具体原因吗？……话说回来，大卫·格雷伯花了不少时间思考现实生活中形形色色的
versions of Michael Scott. He's a professor of anthropology at the London School of Economics and he's the author of the book, Bulsha Jobs, a theory. David, welcome to Hidden Brain. Oh, thank you. So you wrote this essay a couple of years ago that has now turned into a book and you described an entire category of jobs. You call these bullshit jobs and they're not necessarily menial jobs or boring jobs, but they're almost always pointless jobs. Yes, they're actually quite rarely menial. I mean, there are some cases where people say hired as a museum garden told to guard a room of nothing in it. That would be both menial and boring. But most often these jobs are, if nothing else, prestigious and well-paid.
迈克尔·斯科特。他是伦敦政治经济学院的人类学教授，也是《狗屁工作：一种理论》一书的作者。大卫，欢迎来到“隐藏的大脑”。哦，谢谢。几年前你写了一篇随笔，现在这本书就是由它扩充而来的。你在书中描述了一类全新的工作。你称这些为“狗屁工作”，它们不一定是低贱的工作或无聊的工作，但几乎总是毫无意义的工作。是的，它们实际上很少是低贱的。我是说，在某些情况下，比如有人被雇为博物馆看守，被派去守护一个空无一物的房间。那既低贱又无聊。但大多数情况下，这些工作至少可以说是声望高且薪水优厚。
A lot of jobs like this are in middle management, they're clerical, managerial, administrative sort of positions, or their positions in PR, marketing, human resources, almost invariably, they are well paid, with good benefits, and he got a lot of prestige, yet at the same time the people who do them are often report themselves genuinely miserable. They feel they're living a lie, and not only that, they're living a lie against their will. They'd really rather be doing something useful with their lives. So when you wrote this essay a couple of years ago, I'm not quite sure you anticipated this,
很多类似的工作都在中层管理、文书、管理、行政等岗位，或者是公关、市场营销、人力资源等领域的职位。它们几乎无一例外都薪水丰厚、福利优厚，而且社会声望很高，但与此同时，从事这些工作的人却常常感到由衷的痛苦。他们觉得自己像是在活在一个谎言里，不仅如此，他们还是违背意愿地在活在这个谎言里。他们其实更愿意用自己的生命去做一些有意义的事。所以，几年前你写这篇随笔的时候，我猜你并没有预料到……
but the response to the essay was extraordinary. People wrote in from all over the world saying, help, I'm stuck in a BS job. Yeah, I mean all over the world, people seem to recognize themselves in the story I told. And the story I told was almost a joke. You go to these parties and you talk to people who are married to academics or you know in the business world and so what do you do and often to sail nothing really? And you know at first they thought they're just being modest or don't think their job was very interesting but you know apply them over a few drinks and eventually they will often admit that they meant it literally. They literally do nothing. So I wrote in this little piece where I basically said, well, you know, back in the 30s, they thought we'd be working
但外界对这篇随笔的反应非同寻常。世界各地的人们写信来说：救命啊，我被困在一份狗屁工作里了。对，我是说，世界各地的人们似乎都在我讲述的故事中看到了自己的影子。而我讲述的故事几乎像个玩笑。你去参加那些派对，和那些与学者结婚的人交谈，或者你知道的，商业世界里的人。他们会问：“你做什么工作？”通常会回答：“其实也没什么。”你知道的，起初他们以为对方只是在谦虚，或者觉得自己的工作没什么意思。但如果你陪他们喝上几杯，套套话，他们最终通常会承认，他们说的是字面意思。他们真的什么都不做。所以我写了这篇小短文，我在里面基本上说，嗯，你知道的，在上世纪30年代，人们曾认为到了现在，我们每周只需工作
a 15-hour week by now. They thought that, you know, mechanization would mean we'd be living lives of leisure, but instead of just, you know, decreasing the working week, what they seem to have done is just made up these imaginary jobs to keep us all busy. It's almost as if there's some fiendish intelligence making up a pointless position for us to do. How did this happen? And I wrote this piece, and it just went crazy.
15个小时。他们认为，你知道的，机械化意味着我们将过上悠闲的生活，但他们似乎并没有缩短每周的工作时间，而是编造了这些虚构的工作来让我们所有人忙个不停。这几乎就像某种邪恶的智慧在为我们编造一个毫无意义的职位来打发时间。这一切是怎么发生的？我写了这篇文章，然后它就彻底火了。
I really didn't anticipate anything like it. I mean, all over the world, people were translating it, distributing it, server-kept, crashing. Then they put it in newspapers, would run it as a column, and you get these comment sections, which are just amazing. People would say things like, oh my god, it's true. I'm a corporate lawyer, I contribute nothing to humanity, I'm just miserable all the time. Confession started pouring out, so I realized this was a much larger phenomenon than I'd even imagined. I understand that polls have been conducted asking people, do you think your job is meaningless, do you think your job is pointless? What do they tell us? Well, yeah, that actually surprised me, even after the outpouring on the internet, I thought, okay, you know, maybe 15, 20% of jobs are like this. And remember, these are people who think their own jobs are pointless. I mean, I'm not going to go and
我真的没有预料到会有这样的反响。我是说，世界各地的人都在翻译它、传播它，服务器甚至都被挤崩溃了。接着各大报纸把它当作专栏刊登，评论区简直绝了。人们会说这样的话：“哦天哪，太对了。我是一名公司律师，我对人类毫无贡献，我整天都痛苦不堪。”各种坦白如潮水般涌来，我意识到这是一个比我想象的还要庞大的现象。我听说曾有人进行过民意调查，询问人们：你认为你的工作毫无意义吗？你认为你的工作毫无价值吗？调查结果告诉了我们什么？哦，是的，这实际上让我感到惊讶。即使在互联网上收到如潮的好评后，我当时还想，好吧，也许15%到20%的工作是这样的。请记住，这些人认为他们自己的工作是毫无意义的。我是说，我不会去
tell somebody who feels his job is meaningful that they're wrong, but, you know, if you feel you're not doing everything all day, who would know better than you. All right, so after a while, they conducted us some surveys. And one of them was you go. And then later, they did another one in Holland. And they both came up with pretty much exactly the same results between 37 to 40% of all people who had jobs were convinced that if their job didn't exist, it would make no difference at all. That is a huge number, David. It's insane. I had no idea. And that's the people who are sure of it. You know, only 50%
告诉一个觉得自己的工作有意义的人，说他们错了。但是，如果你觉得自己一整天都没在干正事，还有谁能比你更清楚呢？好吧，过了一段时间，他们做了一些调查。其中一项是 YouGov 调查。后来，他们在荷兰又做了一次。这两次调查得出的结果几乎完全一样：所有有工作的人当中，有37%到40%的人确信，如果他们的工作不复存在，将不会产生任何影响。这是一个巨大的数字，大卫。太疯狂了。我完全没想到。而且这还是那些对此深信不疑的人。你知道，只有50%
of people were sure their jobs made a difference, absolutely. And if you think about all the types of jobs, or no one would possibly doubt that they're fulfilling a useful social function, I mean, you know, I'm sure the number of bus drivers, the number of nurses, the number of mechanics and repairmen, also service workers, actually. You know, I eventually asked people to send in testimonies and stories about their most pointless jobs, and almost none of them were in service or retail. It was almost all office workers, almost all people who had jobs where you see them there and
的人绝对确信他们的工作发挥了作用。如果你想想所有那些毫无疑问是在履行有用社会职责的工作，比如公交车司机、护士、机械师和修理工的数量，其实还有服务行业的工作者。你知道的，我最终请人们发来关于他们最无意义工作的证言和故事，结果几乎没有一个是服务业或零售业的。几乎全部都是办公室职员，几乎所有那些你看着他们在那里，然后
you wonder, is that really doing anything? Well, it turns out they're not. David in your book, you described the story of Kurt Kurt who's a German military subcontractor and he feels his job is utterly pointless. Why does he feel this way? Yes, this is one of the first really elaborate examples I got of the kind of job I was talking about given to me spontaneously by someone on the web. Said, I'm a subcontractor to a subcontractor to a subcontractor, all private firms who work for the German military.
心里犯嘀咕的人：“这人真的在干什么吗？”好吧，事实证明，他们确实什么都没干。大卫，在你的书中，你讲述了库尔特的故事。库尔特是一名德国军事分包商，他觉得自己的工作毫无意义。他为什么会有这种感觉？是的，这是我在网上随机收到的关于我所讨论的那类工作的最早、最详细的例子之一。他说：“我是分包商的分包商的分包商，我们都是为德国军方工作的私人公司。”
And he said, you know, because of outsourcing, if a German soldier wants to move his desktop computer from one office to another, he actually has to fill out a bunch of forms He calls human resources they call logistics they call meat Quart, they mustn't even compute our own sterren, but schner And I have to drive 500 kilometers sometimes if a rented car drive to wherever this military base is Fill out a raft of forms put the thing in a box goes down the hall. Somebody else takes out of the box,
他说：“你知道的，因为外包的关系，如果一个德国士兵想把他的台式电脑从一个办公室搬到另一个办公室，他实际上必须填写一堆表格。他打电话给人力资源部，人力资源部打电话给后勤部，后勤部打电话给美因茨的指挥部，甚至还要计算成本和物资分配。有时候我必须开车500公里，开着租来的车去某个军事基地，填一堆表，把东西放进箱子里，然后这东西被送到走廊那头。另一个人把东西从箱子里拿出来，
gives me another form to sign, and then I drive home. And that's his entire job. And one of the interesting things about these jobs is that people were often very confused about how much people knew and how much they could admit. Does my supervisor know that I spend most of the day actually making cat memes? Do they know I'm playing computer games? Am I allowed to say to what degree do my co-workers know? Can I tell them? There's all these questions that people have. How much do I have to pretend to work? And how
给我另一份要签名的表格，然后我就开车回家。”这就是他的全部工作。关于这些工作，有趣的一点是，人们常常对别人知道多少以及能承认多少感到非常困惑。我的主管知道我一天到晚其实都在做猫咪表情包吗？他们知道我在玩电脑游戏吗？我能说吗？我的同事知道到什么程度？我能告诉他们吗？人们心里有各种各样的问题。我要假装工作到什么程度？我又
much am I just allowed to be seen to be just kicking back? And people are very nervous about this. There are all these gray zones. They'll hire someone an engineer in case the air conditioners break. For some reason, they find it impossible to just say, well, you're just here in case the air conditioners break. Otherwise, try to keep the people out of people's way and let them, you know, the internet or do whatever they like all day. Somehow that's not allowed. So they have to make up these rituals, or at the very least you have to pretend to be working because it's considered somehow insulting not to.
能在多大程度上被别人看到我其实是在偷懒？对此，人们感到非常焦虑。这里面有很多灰色地带。他们会雇一个工程师，以防空调坏了。但出于某种原因，他们觉得很难直接说：“哦，你留在这儿就是为了以防空调坏了。除此之外，尽量别碍着别人，想上网还是干嘛都随你便，一整天都行。”不知为什么，这是不允许的。所以他们必须编造这些仪式，或者至少你必须假装在工作，因为被认为不这样做在某种程度上是一种侮辱。
Often people really suffered from that. The fact that A, they had to pretend to some degree. They couldn't just pursue their own projects. And B, they're never quite sure how much they were allowed to pretend. This actually leads us to a story that you describe about your own life. You and some friends signed up to be dishwasher. And something happened on the job. Right. Something happened on the job that made you think about the role of time in how work is constructed. Tell me that story.
通常人们真的深受其害。一方面，他们必须在某种程度上进行伪装，不能只是去追求自己的项目；另一方面，他们永远不确定自己被允许伪装到什么程度。这实际上让我们想到了你在书中描述的关于你自己的生活的一个故事。你和几个朋友曾去应聘洗碗工，结果在工作时发生了一件事。对，工作时发生了一件事，让你开始思考时间在构建工作方式中所起的作用。跟我讲讲那个故事吧。
Okay, this is the very first job I had. I think I was 14 years old, maybe 15. And it was at a beach resort. And I got a job working as a dishwasher in the kitchen. And it was a whole bunch of us who were hired at the same time, we're all about 15 years years old and being 15 year old boys, you know, when the big rush came we took it on as a challenge. We were like, okay, we are going to be the very best dishwashers of all time, you know.
好的，这是我第一份工作。我想我当时14岁，或者15岁。那是在一个海滨度假村，我在厨房里找到了一份洗碗工的工作。我们是一大群人同时被雇用的，大家大约都15岁。作为15岁的男孩，你知道的，当用餐高峰期到来时，我们把它当成了一种挑战。我们当时想：“好吧，我们要成为史上最优秀的洗碗工。”
We're going to be so fast, we're going to be so efficient, the bus is going to be really impressive. You know, we went at it and we like finished it in record time, had this huge, sparkling pile of dishes and kind of kick back. ["The Best of Us"] Boss came in, showing off our handy work, and he was like, what the hell are you guys sitting around for? He said, well, we just finished all the dishes.
我们要以最快的速度、最高的效率完成工作，让吧台的工作人员刮目相看。你知道的，我们全力以赴，以创纪录的速度完成了工作，留下了一大堆闪闪发光的盘子，然后就靠在旁边休息。老板走进来，我们向他展示我们的劳动成果，结果他说：“你们这群家伙坐在这里到底在干嘛？”我们说：“哦，我们刚刚把所有的盘子都洗完了。”
And he said, yeah, well, keep working, you're on my time. You're not, you know, you can lounge around on your own time. And we're like, what do you mean? And I mean, you know, there's nothing to do. And he said, well, clean the baseboards. And said, well, we already clean the baseboards. So to clean them again.
他说：“哦，是吗？继续干活，你们花的是我的时间。你们不能，你知道的，你们不能在我的时间里偷懒闲逛。”我们当时想：“你这话是什么意思？”我是说，你知道的，已经没事可做了。他说：“把踢脚线擦干净。”我们说：“踢脚线我们已经擦过了。”他说：“那就再擦一遍。”
So we realize that there is this kind of weird idea that there is like my time in your time. If I have paid you money, I own your time. And you're not allowed to just kick back. You're not allowed to, you know, there's no point in working fast. That's what we've basically learned. Don't be too efficient because then they'll just make up work and that that
于是我们意识到，存在这样一种奇怪的观念，即时间分为“我的时间”和“你的时间”。如果我付了你钱，我就拥有了你的时间。你不能就这样偷懒，你不能，你知道的，干得快毫无意义。这就是我们学到的基本道理：别太高效，否则他们只会给你凭空捏造活儿干。这种
Experience of doing work that you know is a necessary just because the boss doesn't want to see you being idle is really degrading and it got me to thinking, this concept of my time. How can your time belong to someone else? How can you rent time? And I started doing a little research, and I realized, not at the time, but since, that this is a really weird concept that just never would have occurred to most people who've ever lived.
去做明知不必要的工作的体验，仅仅是因为老板不想看到你闲着，这真的非常贬低人格。这让我开始思考，“我的时间”这个概念。你的时间怎么会属于别人呢？你怎么能把时间租出去呢？我开始做一些研究，并意识到——不是在当时，而是后来——这其实是一个非常奇怪的概念，对于历史上绝大多数人来说，这种想法根本连想都不会想到。
And in the ancient world, if you see a potter, if you're an ancient Roman or an ancient world, if you see a potter, if you're an ancient Roman, or an ancient Greek, you could see a potter and you could imagine buying the pot, that's easy, right? You could imagine buying the potter, they had slavery, but the idea that you could rent this potter's time was just bizarre, it just never would have occurred to anybody. It takes a whole series of very complicated philosophical and also technological changes that make it possible to take time, make it into uniform units that can then therefore be bought and sold.
在古代世界，如果你看到一个陶工，如果你是一个古罗马人或古代世界的人，如果你看到一个陶工，如果你是一个古罗马人或古希腊人，你可以想象买下这个陶器，这很简单，对吧？你可以想象买下这个陶工（当时有奴隶制），但租用这个陶工的时间这种想法简直荒谬绝伦，任何人都不可能会有这种想法。这需要经历一系列非常复杂的哲学以及技术变革，才使得把时间分割成可以买卖的统一单位成为可能。
You teach at the London School of Economics, but before that you worked at Yale University, in your book, David, you point out that the cost of education has skyrocketed in many parts of the world. The reason isn't that teachers are being paid more than they were before. Instead you say universities have gone out and hired an army of workers who are doing BS jobs. Yeah, this is actually really market in America and America I have the statistics. The number of administrators has gone up quite sharply, much more so than teachers.
你在伦敦政治经济学院教书，但在那之前你在耶鲁大学工作过。大卫，你在书中指出，世界许多地方的教育成本已经飙升。原因并不是教师的薪水比以前更高了。相反，你指出大学雇佣了一大批做着“狗屁工作”的行政人员。是的，这在美洲（美国）确实非常明显，我有统计数据。行政人员的数量急剧上升，远超教师。
But even more important than that, the number of administrative staff has just skyrocketed. It's like 240% increase over the last 30 years. So administrative staff basically mean all those guys who work for the deans, for the vice provost, all these endless positions are constantly making up. And what seems to be going on is that these people are being hired essentially for little reason other than making the people now running the universities who are no longer the teachers no longer the professors, but rather top administrators. Basically feel good about themselves, feel important.
但比这更重要的是，行政人员的数量简直呈火箭般飙升。在过去30年里，大约增长了240%。所以行政人员基本上是指那些为院长、副校长工作的所有人，这些无休止的职位正在不断被创造出来。目前的情况似乎是，雇佣这些人基本上没有什么别的理由，除了让那些现在管理大学的人——他们不再是教师，不再是教授，而是高层行政人员——
They hire these guys who are basically there, almost like feudal retainers. You know, I get hired as a vice provost. So obviously I need four or five assistants. You know, they decide what the assistants will actually do later. Systems trying to figure out something to do. So these are the assistants I know. I'll fill out, you know, I'll do a time allocation study. And then suddenly people like me have to spend hours of every week filling out time allocation
自我感觉良好，觉得自己很重要。他们雇佣这些基本上类似于封建家臣的人。你知道的，我被聘为副校长，所以很显然我需要四五个助理。你知道的，他们以后再决定让助理具体做什么。助理则绞尽脑汁想事情做。这就是我所知道的那些助理。我会填一份……你知道的，我会做一份时间分配研究。然后突然之间，像我这样的人每周必须花好几个小时填写时间分配研究，
studies breaking down exactly what I do every hour of the day. So I can't actually do stuff as I'm filling out the forms. And this is how it works. Like the more of these guys there are in these bullshit jobs, the less time the people with real jobs have to actually do their work. And this isn't just universities. I mean, the same things happening in hospitals. More and more hospital administrators
详细列出我一天中每个小时都在做什么。所以我根本无法真正做事，因为我都在填表。事情就是这样运作的。从事这些狗屁工作的人越多，拥有真正工作的人实际做工作的时间就越少。不仅仅是大学，医院里也在发生同样的事情。越来越多的医院行政人员
means nurses have to spend more and more time doing paperwork and less time nursing. Primary school, same thing. Teachers just have to spend all their time in meetings and reports. Okay, by this point you might be looking around at fellow commuters, at co-workers, at friends, and asking yourself which people find their work boring and pointless. It turns out there are tales to identify people doing bullshit jobs. Stay with us.
意味着护士不得不花越来越多的时间处理文书工作，而用于护理病人的时间却越来越少。小学也是如此。老师们不得不把所有的时间都花在开会和写报告上。好了，听到这里，你可能会环顾四周的通勤同伴、同事、朋友，然后在心里盘问自己：究竟哪些人会觉得自己的工作既无聊又毫无意义？事实证明，确实有一些迹象可以帮我们识别从事“狗屁工作”的人。请稍候，我们马上回来。
Working a bullshit job might feel like an exercise in futility, a task that seems completely pointless. In truth, there's a perverse logic that shapes how and why these jobs come to be. David Graber has brought an anthropologist's eye to the life of the board office worker, and he's come up with a classification system for different kinds of BS jobs. The first category is something he calls a duct taper.
做一份狗屁工作，感觉就像是一场徒劳的练习，一项完全毫无意义的任务。事实上，背后有一种扭曲的逻辑在决定着这些工作如何以及为何诞生。大卫·格雷伯用人类学家的目光审视了死板的办公室白领的生活，并为不同种类的“狗屁工作”提出了一套分类系统。第一类被称为“胶带工”。
Rather than fix serious headaches, many organizations take the easy route. They paper over the problem. David has a revealing story from his own life. This was quite early on in my time in the UK university system. And they had this shelf in my office. I was always a little worried about it. It seemed kind of precarious. And one day it was completely ripped out of the wall. There was this huge gaping hole in the wall.
许多组织并没有去解决严重的沉疴顽疾，而是选择走捷径。他们用纸把问题糊弄过去。大卫讲了一个来自他自己生活的揭示性故事。那是在我进入英国大学系统的不久之后。我办公室里有一个书架，我一直有点担心它，它看起来摇摇欲坠的。有一天，它彻底从墙上扯了下来。墙上留下了一个巨大的骇人窟窿，
There was kind of mangled metal hanging over my desk. So obviously in a way I could fix it myself. And so I called buildings and grounds. And they said, OK, we'll send a carpenter. And it took about a week and a half for the carpenter to show up and people in the office were calling I was calling everybody was calling and it became this daily ritual and I gradually realized there's one guy we always got the same guy whose entire job seemed to consist of apologizing for the fact that the carpenter was very busy and couldn't come. And one day it occurred to me like, well, why don't they just fire that guy and hire a second
有些扭曲的金属挂在我的办公桌上方。所以显然，在某种程度上我可以自己修理它。于是我打电话给基建与后勤部门。他们说：“好的，我们会派个木匠来。”木匠花了大约一个半星期才出现，办公室里的人一直在打电话，我也在打电话，每个人都在打，这成了一种日常仪式。我渐渐意识到，总有这么一个人——我们遇到的总是同一个人——他的全部工作似乎就是为“木匠非常忙、抽不开身”这件事道歉。有一天我突然想到：为什么他们不直接解雇这个人，然后雇第二个
carpenter? He'll be, then he won't need him, right? And I mentioned this to various people and they looked at me like, yeah, right, that would ever happen. And I realized that this is a perfect example of a bolted job. His job is only necessitated because the system is stupidly constructed. So he's there to see equivalent of if you had a leak
木匠呢？那样的话，就不需要他了，对吧？我向不同的人提过这件事，他们看着我的表情就像在说：“得了吧，这种事怎么可能会发生。”我意识到这是“胶带工”工作的一个完美例子。他的工作之所以存在，纯粹是因为这个系统结构愚蠢。所以他的存在就相当于，如果你的屋顶漏水，
in the roof, instead of fixing the roof, you hire some guy to empty a bucket every hour. It's a totally pointless position. And gradually, I realized that in the software industry industry at least this is called duct taping. I want to talk about a second category of Bush's job, David. This one involves managers who come up with meaningless assignments for their subordinates. You called them taskmasters? That's right. Now a taskmaster is a type of bullshit job which involves one,
你不去修屋顶，而是雇一个人每小时去倒一次水桶。这是一个完全毫无意义的职位。渐渐地，我意识到在软件行业里，至少这种做法被称为“打补丁（胶带固定）”。大卫，我想谈谈第二类狗屁工作。这一类涉及那些为下属想出毫无意义的任务的管理人员。你称他们为“工头”？没错。现在，“工头”是一种狗屁工作，包含两个不同的类别，实际上分为两种。其中一种很简单，就是去监管那些根本不需要监管的人。许多中层管理者写信告诉我，他们干的就是那种工作。通常他们做过某项工作，然后晋升到了管理层，所以他们知道这份工作包含什么内容，也知道根本不需要对下属进行任何监管，但他们还是得装出在监管的样子。另一种则正是我在大学案例中所描述的那种。人们的工作最终似乎变成了为其他人创造文书工作和不必要的任务。所以再次回到中层管理的例子，假设你做过某项工作，然后你被提升去监督这项工作，而你深知他们根本不需要监督。慢慢地，你会意识到，与其整天坐在这里，为了在老板面前表现得好一点，你能做的最好的事情大概就是建立某种目标系统。给他们分配文书工作，以确保他们达到目标，这样就会有东西需要归档和处理，你也就有事情可做了。最经典的例子来自一个名叫克洛伊的女性的故事。她是为数不多愿意向我坦白的高层学术行政人员之一。她说：“嗯，你知道的，我接受了非执行院长这个职位。”她说“非执行”基本上意味着你没有权力，不掌控资金。所以你是战略性的。你应该想出点子，但你没有真正的能力让任何人去执行。所以本质上她做的是一份毫无意义的工作，她想出一个计划，然后根本没有人理睬。然而，她照样被指派了三个助理。事情就是这样。一旦你得到了一个声望很高的职位，他们立刻就会给你配备助理，然后你必须想办法给他们找点事做。在她的情况中，他们三个都没有任何显而易见的职能，所以她不得不把时间花在编造任务上，免得他们因为整天闲坐着而惹上麻烦。
there's two different types actually. One of them is simply a supervisor of people who don't need supervision. And a lot of middle managers wrote to me and said that they had that kind of job. Often they'd done a certain job, they got promoted to management, so they knew what was entailed doing the job, and they knew that basically they didn't need supervision at all, but they had to pretend they were supervising them anyway. But another type is exactly what I was describing in the case of universities. People whose job seems to end up being creating paperwork and unnecessary tasks for other people to do. So again, to go back to the middle management example, say you did have a job and you got
事实上，主要有两种不同的类型。其中一种仅仅是监督那些根本不需要监督的人。许多中层管理者写信告诉我，他们从事的就是这种工作。通常，他们做过某项工作后被提拔到了管理层，所以他们知道这项工作包含什么内容，也知道实际上他们根本不需要监督，但他们还是得假装在监督。而另一种类型正是我在大学里所描述的那种。他们的工作最终似乎变成了为其他人制造文书工作和不必要的任务。所以再次回到中层管理的例子，假设你有一份工作，然后你被
promoted to supervising that job and you knew that they didn't need supervision. Gradually, you would realize that rather than to sit here all day, probably the best thing you could do to make look good to your boss is to create some kind of target system. Give them paperwork to do to make sure they're hitting their targets and then there'll be something to file in process and you'll have something that you can do. The classic example comes from the story of a woman named Chloe. She was one of the few people who was in academic administration in the higher echelons who was willing to
提拔去监督这项工作，而你知道他们并不需要监督。渐渐地，你会意识到，与其整天坐在这里，为了在老板面前表现好，你最好做的一件事就是建立某种目标体系。给他们派发文书工作以确保他们达到目标，然后就会有东西可以存档处理，你也就有事情可做了。最经典的例子来自一个名叫克洛伊（Chloe）的女人的故事。她是高等教育行政管理高层中少数几个愿意
come forward and admit this to me. She said, well, you know, I took on this job as a non-executive dean. She says non-executive basically means you have no power, you don't control money. So you're strategic. You're supposed to come up with ideas, but you have no real ability to make anybody do that. So essentially she had a pointless job, she would come up with a plan and then nobody would pay any attention. However, she was given three assistants again. That's what happens. As soon as you get a prestigious position, they immediately give you assistance and then you have to figure out something for them to do. In her case, none of them had any obvious function, so she had to spend her time making up things for them to do so they wouldn't get in trouble for just sitting around.
所以，你可以有这样的狗屁工作：帮助老板感觉自己并非可有可无（哪怕他其实就是可有可无）。你可以有这样的狗屁工作：旨在掩盖某个组织无法或不想解决的问题。大卫还描述了第三种狗屁工作。表面上看，这些工作并非毫无意义，但一个组织保留它们的唯一原因，是因为其他组织也有。大卫把从事这些工作的人称为“喽啰”。我问他这个词是什么意思。我不得不编造这个词，因为有太多人
So you can have BS jobs to help the boss feel like he's actually necessary when he isn't. You can have BS jobs that are designed to paper over problems that an organization cannot or does not want to fix. David also describes a third type of BS job. On the surface, these jobs are not pointless, but the only reason an organization has them is because other organizations have them. David calls the people who work these jobs goons. I asked him what he meant by the term. I had to make that up because so many people
写信向我诉说那些我没有预料到的工作。这些工作包含某种侵略性元素，对公司来说可能显得必要或有用。它们并非完全没用，但从事这些工作的人觉得它们根本不该存在，主要是因为他们觉得整个行业或职业都是不必要的。所以电话推销员就是一个很好的例子。你好，韦丹坦先生。我今天打电话来为您提供一个特别优惠……电话推销员对此深有体会，我是说，95%的电话推销员肯定都坚信，如果所有的电话推销员都在一团烟雾中消失，世界会变得更美好。但很多公司律师也是这么想的。我是说，当然，有些高层会争辩说：“不，
wrote to me with jobs that I hadn't really anticipated. Jobs which involved a certain element of aggression, which might have seen necessary or helpful to the corporation. They weren't completely useless, but that the people doing them felt shouldn't exist anyway, largely because they felt the entire industry or profession was unnecessary So telemarketers were a great example. Hi, Mr. Vitton. I'm calling today with a special offer for you Telemarketers felt strongly that I mean 95% of telemarkers I'm sure feel strongly that if all telemarketers were to vanish in a puff of smoke the world would be a better place But a lot of corporate lawyers feel that way too. I mean, sure, there's some higher ups who would argue, no,
公司法非常重要，它把一切维系在一起。”但大多数我交谈过的公司律师，通常是级别较低的律师，都会说：“得了吧。我是说，如果整个行业都消失了，那将是一件大好事。”我是说，你只需要一个公司律师，因为别人也有公司律师。这有点像封建时代的骑士。人们总是说封建领主存在是为了保护
corporate law is very important, it holds things together. But most corporate lawyers I've talked to, usually lower ranking ones, will say, oh, come on. I mean, if this entire industry were to disappear, it would be great. I mean, you only need a corporate lawyer because somebody else has a corporate lawyer. It's a little like a feudal lawyer. They always say feudal lords are there to protect the
农民。这是他们收取封建地租的正当理由。但如果你深入探究一下，他们是在保护农民免受谁的侵害呢？是其他封建领主的侵害。所以如果没有封建领主，封建领主也就没必要存在了。这就是为什么我称他们为“喽啰”。这里面有一种侵略性的成分。但另一方面，他们之所以存在，仅仅是因为其他同样具有侵略性的人存在。大卫说，另一种狗屁工作是“随从”。这类工作的主要存在目的，就是让某人或
peasants. That's their justification for taking feudal rents. But if you really look into the matter, who are they protecting the peasants from? Other feudal lords. So if there were no feudal lords, feudal lords would be unnecessary. So that's why I called them goons. There's an element of aggression there. But on the other hand, they're only there because other such aggressive people exist. David says another BS job is the flunky. These jobs primarily exist to make someone or
某事看起来威风凛凛。过去的经典随从包括门童或仪仗侍卫等。我一直很好奇仪仗侍卫到底是干什么的。你在《爱丽丝梦游仙境》和19世纪的这些书里总是能读到他们。你知道仪仗侍卫是干什么的吗？他们就是那些穿着非常华丽、像军服一样衣服的人。他们实际做的事情是，跑在人们的马车前面，寻找路上的颠簸和坑洼。所以整个概念就是，如果我有一个仆人专门来做这件——基本上有点多余、并非完全必要的事情，那就说明我非常有钱、非常重要，你们应该知道这一点。这就是典型的随从。通常，随从会被指派一项非常微不足道的任务，
something look impressive. Classic flunkies of the past have included things like dormant or footmen. I always wondered what a footman actually was. You always read about them in Allison Wunderland in these 19th century books. You know what a footman worked? They were the guys who were these really fancy military looking uniforms. What the thing they actually did was they ran in front of people's carriages looking for bumps in the road. So a whole idea is if I have a servant just to do this one, basically kind of superfluous, not really totally necessary thing, I'm really rich and important so you should know that. And that's a classic flunky. Often flunkies will be assigned one very minor task,
有点像在比武前用镊子帮领主修剪胡须的人之类的。但实际上他们的存在只是为了让所有人知道：我有大把的仆人。但在企业界也是如此，因为在企业界，一个高管的实际地位往往是用有多少人在他手下干活来衡量的。所以他没有任何动力去裁掉多余的员工。事实上，你经常会听到有人说：“是的，我在这儿就是为了让别人看起来很重要或显得很重要。”前台接待员经常这么说。显然，有些前台接待员非常忙，有着真正的工作，但也有一些
sort of like the guy who tweezes the lords mustash before a jaust or something like that. But really they're just there so that everybody can know I've got lots of servants. But in the corporate world is very much the same, because in the corporate world, the actual status of an executive is often measured by how many people work on dirt. So he has no incentive to get rid of unnecessary employees. And in fact, you often find people saying, yeah, I'm just there to make someone else look important or seem important. Receptionists often say that. Obviously, some receptionists are very busy and have a real job, but there are some
前台接待员，你知道的，也许他们一天只接一个电话。除此之外，他们就是换换糖果碗，或者，你知道的，给植物浇浇水什么的，但基本上他们就是闲坐着。那为什么还要设前台接待员呢？你知道的，如果一天只有一个电话，他们完全可以自己接听，对吧？原因在于，如果你没有前台接待员，你看上去就不像一家真正的公司。公司最终落得一堆狗屁工作的一个原因，在于有时想要摆脱那些表现不佳的人是困难的、不可能的、
receptionists who, you know, maybe they get one phone call a day too. Otherwise, they change the candy bowl or, you know, water the plants or something, but basically they're just sitting around. So why do they have receptionists at all? You know, if it's just one call a day, they could just take the call themselves, right? The reason why is because if you don't have a receptionist, you don't look like a real corporation. One reason the companies end up with BS jobs is that it's sometimes difficult or impossible
或者是令人不快的。你提到了那个为木匠没出现而道歉的家伙的例子。现在，情况可能只是解雇那家伙并雇佣另一个木匠在行政上会很繁琐。所以，跟我聊聊这个想法：部分问题实际上可能仅仅在于
or unpleasant to get rid of people who are not functioning well. You mentioned the example of the guy who's apologizing for the carpenter not showing up. Now, it could just be that getting rid of that guy and hiring another carpenter might be administratively onerous. So, talk to me about this idea that part of the problem might actually just be
组织运作方式的僵化，与其直接解雇你不想要的人并找到你想要的人，你有时最终只能留下那个你不想要的人，或者现在再雇一个新人来做你实际上需要完成的工作。这其实是我最喜欢的例子之一，因为，你知道的，“工头”显然是最难让他们承认并寄来关于到底发生了什么的证言的人，但我确实收到了几个。其中一个人的说法恰好就是这样。大型官僚机构中之所以最终会出现这么多狗屁工作，原因之一在于如果某人资历深厚，而且你知道的，
rigidity in how organizations work and instead of basically getting rid of the person you don't want and finding the person you do want, you end up sometimes just keeping the person you don't want or now hiring an additional person to come in and do the job that you actually do need to get done. That was one of my favorite examples actually, because I, you know, the taskmasters are obviously the ones that were most difficult to get them to fess off and tell send in testimonies about what's going on, but I got a couple. And one of them said exactly that. One reason that you end up getting so many bullshit jobs in large bureaucracies is if someone has seniority and you know
以往报告良好，那么要解雇他们几乎是不可能的。所以如果他们突然变成了酒鬼，或者仅仅是（你知道的）对工作失去了兴趣，变得不称职，最简单的做法不是解雇他们，而是雇另一个人来做他们的工作。但如果你雇了另一个人来做他们的工作，你又不能承认他们正在做这份工作，对吧？所以你必须编造一份不同的工作。然后你往往还得引导他们，让他们（你知道的）把某些内容写进
good reports, well it's almost impossible to fire them. So if suddenly they become a drunk or just you know lose interest in the job, become bad at what they do, the easiest thing to do instead of getting rid of them is to hire someone else to do their job. But if you hire someone else to do their job, you can't admit that they're doing their job, right? So you have to make up a different job. And then often you have to walk them through, get them, you know, tell them what to put on
简历里，让他们看起来好像能做这另外一件事。尽管实际上他们要做的（你知道的）是那个酒鬼在做的事。你知道的，于是你就有了一套精心编排的仪式来创造虚假工作。然后，你知道的，当那个人离开时，你可能需要雇人来真正做那份编造出来的工作。这变得无休止地荒谬、异化而又繁琐。我们在这里所做的是，迈克尔处理更多宏观层面的事情，而我处理更多日常的事情。所以加在一起，我想我明白了。
their CV so they look like they can do this other thing. Even though really they're going to be doing, you know, what the drunk guy does. And you know, so you have these elaborate rituals of creating dummy jobs. And then, you know, when that guy goes, you might need to hire someone to actually do the made up job. And it just becomes endlessly mocky of alien and elaborate. What we're doing here, Michael handles more of the big picture stuff. And I handle more of the day-to-day stuff. So together, I think I understand.
好吧。你们俩每个人都在做半份工作。不。有时我简直应付不了这个。对。当我们回来时，我们将探讨从事一份不仅让你感到无聊、而且你认为毫无意义的工作所带来的心理后果。我想谈谈你所描述的、由
All right. Each of you is doing half a job. No. Sometimes I can hardly handle that. Yeah. When we come back, the psychological consequences of working in a job that you not only find boring, but that you think is meaningless. I want to talk about the range of psychological effects that you described that arise from
做这些狗屁工作所引发的一系列心理影响。我想从你引用的一项在婴儿身上进行的研究开始，你说这项研究所展现的恰恰是有意义工作的价值。那是一项怎样的研究？是的，那真的很有趣。我曾听到过这样一种表述，它一直留在我脑海里——“身为诱因的快乐”。不知为什么，这对我来说一直很有道理。你知道的，我们所做的很多事情，看起来很有趣，似乎并没有什么目的，但仅仅是知道自己能够做成事情本身就挺有意思的。事实上，曾有一位德国心理学家试图提出一个关于
doing these kinds of BS jobs. And I want to begin with research that you cite that was done amongst babies, that you say sort of shows the value of meaningful work. What was the research? Yeah, that was really interesting. I'd heard this expression and I'd always stuck in my head, the pleasure at being a cause. It's always some made sense to me somehow. You know, a lot of what we do, which seems fun, doesn't seem to have any point, but it's just like knowing that you can do things itself is kind of fun. And indeed, there was a German psychologist who was trying to come up with a
游戏的理论。他注意到一个非常有趣的现象：他发现婴儿在刚开始试图弄清楚自己是谁的时候，由于起初婴儿甚至不理解自己是一个独立于周围世界的个体，他们到哪里结束、世界从哪里开始对他们来说并不清晰，他们感觉自己与母亲或周围环境是连为一体的。好吧，所以婴儿实际上是如何弄清楚自己是一个独立个体的呢？
theory of play actually. And he noticed something very interesting. He noticed that infants when they're first trying to figure out who they are. Because at first infants don't even really understand that they are a discrete entity separate from the world around them, where they stop and the world starts is not clear to them. They're kind of continuous, so their mother or their continuous, their environment. Okay, so, so baby actually figure out that they are discreet entity. At the moment, they realize they can have predictable effects on the world. So there's some point where a child say they're moving their arm around and they move something on the table. No, like move a pencil. And they realize if they move their arm the same way, the pencil will move in the same way as well And the moment where they realize that there's this sort of feeling of incredible happiness comes over a troll
就在他们意识到自己可以对世界产生可预测的影响的那一刻。所以有那么一个点，比如说一个孩子在挥舞手臂，他们移动了桌上的某个东西。比如，移动了一支铅笔。他们意识到，如果他们以同样的方式挥舞手臂，铅笔也会以同样的方式移动。而当他们意识到这一点的那个瞬间，一种难以置信的幸福感便涌上心头。
You can see them just let a absolute joy and delight like Wow, I can move a pencil. This is great. It'll happen the same way every time and and That moment they say is the moment you realize that you are something different from the world. You know, you are a thing that can have effects on the world. And what they argue is that sense of self is tied up with that kind of joyous realization that you can have effects on the world. What happens when small children are prevented from influencing their worlds?
你能看到他们流露出绝对的快乐和喜悦，仿佛在说：“哇，我能移动铅笔了。这太棒了！”每次都会以同样的方式发生。他们说，那个时刻就是你意识到自己与世界有所不同的时刻。你知道的，你是一个能够对世界产生影响的存在。他们的观点是，这种自我意识与那种能够对世界产生影响的快乐觉醒紧密相连。当小孩子被阻止影响他们的世界时，会发生什么？
David says the experience of decline in well-being and efficacy. Kids freak out, you know, they go from being incredibly happy to being really confused and upset. You're blocked from having any meaningful to being really confused and upset. You're blocked from having any meaningful effect on the world around you. You kind of collapse. Now I really think that's what's happening, in the case of bullshit jobs. People suddenly become incredibly depressed.
大卫说，这会导致幸福感和效能感的下降。小家伙们会抓狂，你知道的，他们会从极度快乐变得极其困惑和沮丧。你被剥夺了对周围世界产生任何有意义影响的权利，整个人就会崩溃。现在我真的认为，这就是狗屁工作所发生的情况。人们突然变得极其沮丧。
They lose all motivation. They don't understand why they feel that way. That's, you know, in a way, they think I should be happy, right, on getting paid money to do nothing. Something for nothing, that's a great deal, but why am I so miserable? I think that's the reason. I remember once talking with Peter Ubel, he's a researcher at Duke University. He once conducted a study. He told volunteers that they could sit silently, no iPhones, no distractions, nothing for five minutes, and if they did that, they would get $2.50.
他们失去了所有的动力，他们不明白自己为什么会有这种感觉。你知道的，在某种程度上，他们会想：“我应该感到高兴才对啊，拿着钱却什么都不用做。”不劳而获，这多划算啊，但为什么我却这么痛苦呢？我想这就是原因。我记得曾与杜克大学的研究人员彼得·乌贝尔交谈过。他曾做过一项研究。他告诉志愿者，他们可以静静地坐着，没有iPhone，没有干扰，什么都不要做，持续五分钟，如果做到了，他们就能得到2.50美元。
He also told them that they could spend the time solving very, very difficult problems. And he asked them how much would they want to be paid for doing the puzzles instead of doing nothing. Here's what Ubel told me. We found that the large majority of the students said we'd have to pay them more than $2.50 to solve the word puzzles. And yet when we actually finished the five minutes and asked them how much they enjoyed those five minutes, the people solving the word puzzles enjoyed the five minutes and asked them how much they enjoyed those five minutes,
他还告诉他们，他们可以用这些时间来解决非常非常困难的问题。他问他们，如果做这些拼图而不是无所事事，他们希望得到多少报酬。乌贝尔是这样对我的：我们发现，绝大多数学生说，我们必须付给他们超过2.50美元的报酬，他们才愿意解字谜。然而，当我们真正完成了五分钟的测试，并问他们对这五分钟的享受程度时，那些解字谜的人却很享受这五分钟……
the people solving the word puzzles enjoyed the five minutes significantly more. And yet very few of them said, yeah, pay me two dollars and I'd be happy to do word puzzles because at least I'll be having fun. One implication from the study, David, is that people don't fully appreciate all the dimensions of a job when they apply for it. So you might think, hey, it's great to get paid money for doing absolutely nothing, but the issue of boredom, the issue of meaninglessness, the issue of pointlessness, these things become salient only after you've started doing the job. So in some ways, are our psychological biases partly to blame for the proliferation of
那些解字谜的人对这五分钟的享受程度要显著得多。然而，很少有人会说，‘好吧，付给我两美元，我就会很乐意去做字谜，因为至少我会觉得很有趣。’戴维，这项研究的一个启示是，人们在申请一份工作时，并没有完全体会到这份工作的各个维度。所以你可能会想，‘嘿，什么都不做就能拿钱，这太棒了。’但无聊的问题、毫无意义的问题、毫无价值的问题，这些问题只有在你开始工作后才会凸显出来。所以在某种程度上，我们的心理偏见是否也是导致这种现象蔓延的原因之一……
BS jobs? Well, I think it's partly to that we're all taught that people want something for nothing. I mean, think about economics. What does economics teach you? Basically, that we all want something for nothing. That, you know, people wish to get the maximum benefit for the least expenditure of time and resources, an effort. So, you know, according to economics, anybody who's handed a job where they're paid good money to do nothing should be happy as a clam, you know.
……狗屁工作？嗯，我认为部分原因在于，我们从小就被教导人们想要不劳而获。我的意思是，想想经济学。经济学教给你什么？基本上，我们都想不劳而获。你知道的，人们希望以最少的时间、资源和精力的支出获得最大的利益。所以，你知道的，根据经济学的观点，任何得到一份拿高薪却什么都不用干的工作的人，都应该高兴得像个快乐的蛤蜊，你知道的。
But, so, one of the strange things is that people don't understand why they aren't happy. They're we're given this false assumption about what people are basically about and what people are basically like. You you argue that there are even spiritual consequences of BS jobs and one of them is something that you call scriptlessness. What do you mean by that? I remember being very impressed by a psychological study which looked at people, you know, sort of looked at times they'd been in love or people had been in love with them when they were teenagers and how they'd managed to integrate the experience or especially unrequited love. And what they found out was that, you know, if you're in love with someone who does not return your feelings,
但是，奇怪的事情之一就是，人们不明白为什么自己并不快乐。我们被灌输了关于人们的本质以及人们基本状态的错误假设。你认为狗屁工作甚至会带来精神上的后果，其中之一就是你所说的“无剧本化”。你这话是什么意思？我记得曾对一项心理学研究印象深刻，该研究观察了人们——比如观察了他们十几岁时恋爱或被人追求的经历，以及他们如何设法整合这种经历，尤其是单恋。他们发现，如果你爱上了一个没有回应你感情的人……
well, it's difficult, but you can come up with a story about it. People had come to terms with it. They almost remembered the incidents fondly 20 years later. It was the people who had other people who were in love with them who didn't actually feel the same way about them, who were still kind of hurt. They were really confused.
嗯，这很艰难，但你可以编出一个关于它的故事。人们已经接受了它。20年过去了，他们甚至还能深情地回忆起这些事情。而那些被别人爱着、但实际上对对方没有同样感觉的人，依然会受到某种伤害。他们真的很困惑。
They felt guilty, but they felt indignant, and they just didn't know how to feel. And one of the reasons why they suggested is because, you know, if you're in love with someone who doesn't love you, you know exactly how you're supposed to feel. There's like 2,000 years of literature telling you exactly how you're supposed to feel, how you're supposed to behave, what's appropriate, what isn't. Whereas if you're on the other side, you're pretty much at a loss. You know, there are no novels written from the point of view of Roxanne instead of, you know, Sierra-No.
他们感到内疚，但也感到愤怒，只是不知道该有什么样的感受。他们给出的原因之一是，如果你爱上了一个不爱你的人，你非常清楚自己应该有什么样的感受。就像有两千年的文学作品准确地告诉你应该有什么样的感受、应该如何行为、什么才是恰当的、什么是不恰当的。然而，如果你处于另一端，你几乎就会感到无所适从。你知道，没有多少小说是以罗克珊的视角而不是西拉诺的视角来写的。
And so those people didn't have a script. In a very similar way, it seems like, bullshit, jobs put one in a similar situation. You don't know how you're supposed to feel about this. You should be happy, but you're not. You can't, don't know if you can talk about it. You don't know who you can confer. There's no kind of anchor to give yourself a sense of what's going on
因此，这些人没有剧本。以非常类似的方式，狗屁工作似乎也把人置于类似的境地。你不知道自己对这种工作该有什么样的感受。你本该快乐，但你并不快乐。你不知道自己是否能谈论它。你不知道自己能向谁倾诉。没有什么锚能给你一种正在发生的事情的感觉……
or what you should think or do about it. One of the most interesting ideas you explore is that in many countries we have a fetish about work. We think a person who's working a job, even if it's a BS job, is in some ways a better human being than the person who's just hanging out. So it seems like there's a moral component to this whole belief structure. Absolutely. I think this cannot be understood, except through looking at the history of, well, for one thing, religion. I mean, if you look at the story of the Garden of Eden, or even Hesiod's story of Prometheus, they both have the same basic theme, which is that, you know, we have to work because we
或者你应该对此有什么想法或做什么。你探讨的最有趣的观点之一是，在许多国家，我们对工作有一种盲目的迷恋。我们认为一个有工作的人，即使是一份狗屁工作，在某种程度上也比一个只是闲逛的人更好。所以整个信仰结构似乎包含着一个道德成分。绝对是这样。我认为，如果不通过观察历史，尤其是宗教的历史，就无法理解这一点。我的意思是，如果你看看伊甸园的故事，或者赫西俄德关于普罗米修斯的传说，它们都有相同的主题，那就是，你知道，我们必须工作是因为我们……
disobeyed the gods, or we disobeyed God. We rebelled and we're punished. And God's recedence is creator. So in a way, we are punished. They said, you want to be like God? Fine. Be like God. You can create the world. But it'll be painful and miserable. So there's this notion that a work is productive and b that it is suffering and that it's kind of our punishment for our own arrogance. But at the same time, it's seen as moralizing, you know, through working we become an adult, become a real mature, self-contained, like human being, as opposed to kids who are just all over the place, right?
违背了神意，或者违背了上帝。我们反叛了，受到了惩罚。上帝是创造者。所以在某种程度上，我们受到了惩罚。他们说：‘你想和上帝一样吗？好的。就像上帝一样吧。你可以创造这个世界。但这将是痛苦和悲惨的。’因此有一种观念认为，工作一方面是生产性的，另一方面是痛苦的，这是我们对自身傲慢的惩罚。但与此同时，它也被视为一种道德教化，你知道，通过工作我们成长为成年人，成为真正成熟、独立、完整的人，而不是那些到处疯跑的孩子，对吧？
You know, through working, becoming an adult. So all of these ideas, work as production, work as punishment, work as necessary to retain maturity, all kind of bundled together. And what's happened is that there is this idea now that if you're not doing something, something you don't really enjoy, you're not working harder at it than you really want to be working, preferably for someone you don't like very much, you know, you don't like very much. You're just a bad person. You're not a real adult, certainly, and you're probably just some lazy parasite who doesn't deserve the help or support of their community.
你知道，通过工作成为成年人。因此，所有这些观念——工作是生产、工作是惩罚、工作是保持成熟所必需的——都交织在了一起。发生的情况是，现在有了这样一种观念：如果你没有在做某事，没有在做一件你并不是真正喜欢的事，如果你工作得不够努力（超过了你真正愿意付出的程度），最好还是为了一个你并不是很喜欢的老板工作，那么你就是一个坏人。你肯定算不上真正的成年人，而且你可能只是某个不配得到社区帮助或支持的懒惰寄生虫。
And that idea has been just drilled into people, like, incisantly, for the last 30, 40 years. Isn't it possible that there are actually jobs that people might find meaningless or pointless, but that are, in fact, useful or essential. I mean, to take your example, it does seem absurd to ask Kurt to drive, you know, a hundred miles to help move a computer 15 feet. But maybe they have found, I'm just tossing this out, when you factor in liability or regulations or some other set of rules, that this is indeed the cheapest way to do something. So isn't it possible that at least in some cases, bullshed jobs have a purpose that might be invisible to the person who's walking the job? Well, it's possible. And no doubt there are a few cases like that.
这种想法在过去30、40年里一直被不厌其烦地灌输给人们。难道就没有这样一种可能：有些工作人们可能会觉得没有意义或毫无价值，但实际上它们却是有用或必不可少的？我是说，以你的例子来说，要求库尔特开车行驶一百英里去帮忙把一台电脑移动15英尺，这似乎确实很荒谬。但也许他们发现——我只是随口说说——当你把责任、法规或其他一系列规则考虑在内时，这确实是完成某项工作的最便宜的方式。所以，难道就没有这种可能吗？至少在某些情况下，狗屁工作其实有着对身处工作岗位的人来说可能隐形的目的？嗯，这是可能的。毫无疑问，确实存在一些这样的情况。
But I think that the number of cases like that must be far outnumbered by the number of cases where it's the other way around. Because, after all, if there is some way that Kurt's job is really necessary, it seems unlikely that no one's going to explain that to him. On the other hand, if you are working for a magazine that it turns out it doesn't really exist, I had an example like that. A magazine that doesn't exist? Yeah, she was writing for travel magazine.
但我认为，这类情况的数量必定远少于相反情况的数量。因为毕竟，如果库尔特的工作真的有某种必要性，那么似乎不太可能没有人向他解释这一点。另一方面，如果你为一家实际上并不存在的杂志工作——我曾遇到过这样一个例子。一本根本不存在的杂志？是的，她曾为一家旅游杂志撰稿。
One of those ones, they have an airplanes. And gradually, she figured out that it's a scam. Actually, there is no such magazine. They have this whole office full of people preparing copy and illustrations for a magazine that never is actually printed. Why would they do that? She wasn't quite sure.
那是那种刊登在飞机上的杂志。渐渐地，她发现这是一个骗局。实际上根本没有这样一本杂志。他们整个办公室的人都在为一本从未真正印刷过的杂志准备文稿和插图。他们为什么要这么做？她也不是很确定。
She thought it might have to do a tax write-off or they got a grant or some sort of, there's some financial scam going on. There's lots of things like that going on. So if you're involved in a scam or something like that, of course that's a very thing they won't tell you. So if there is a way that your job seems pointless but it's useful, chances are someone
她认为这可能与核销税款有关，或者他们获得了一笔资助什么的，其中存在某种财务骗局。有很多类似的事情正在发生。因此，如果你卷入了某种骗局之类的事情，这当然是他们绝不会告诉你的一点。所以，如果你的工作看起来毫无意义但却有用，那么很有可能有人……
is going to explain that to you just because you want your work as to be motivated. On the other hand, if you're writing reports for a central office and the central office just takes the reports and files and never reads them, probably they're not going to tell you that. I want to talk about the idea that jobs in some ways are jobs. They pay the bills, they cover the mortgage, they allow us to go on vacations. I want to play your clip from the movie Dinner with Schmach's where the lead character
会向你解释这一点，只是因为你希望自己的工作具有动力。另一方面，如果你在为总办公室写报告，而总办公室只是把这些报告收下并存档，却从来不读它们，他们大概是不会告诉你这一点的。我想谈谈这样一种观点：工作在某种程度上就是工作。它们支付账单，偿还房贷，让我们能够去度假。我想播放一段电影《笨人晚宴》中的片段，其中主角……
explains to his girlfriend why he works at a job that he doesn't love. There's you and the me that you know and we love each other and we have a wonderful life. But then there's the me that you don't know and the me that you don't know has to do things sometimes so that you and the me that you know can live in this nice apartment and eat at nice restaurants and go to Cabo for Christmas. He takes care of us. You know what? There should not be any you. I don't know. But there is. You might not like him. I don't like him. I hate him. But we need him. You know, it's like the CIA. The CIA?
向他的女朋友解释了他为什么要做一份自己并不喜欢的工作。这里有你，有你所了解的我，我们彼此相爱，我们拥有美好的生活。但还有一个你所不了解的我，那个你所不了解的我有时必须做一些事情，以便你和那个你所了解的我能够住在这间漂亮的公寓里，在高级餐厅用餐，去卡波过圣诞节。他在照顾我们。你知道吗？根本不应该有这个“你”。我不知道。但确实有。你可能不喜欢他。我也不喜欢他。我恨他。但我们需要他。你知道，这就好比中情局。中情局？
Mm-hmm. The CIA does some pretty funky nasty stuff in the shadows, but I for one am glad they're there. What do you think David? If we didn't have BS jobs, how would millions of people get paid? Well, there's a lot of ways you could solve that problem. Probably the easiest one would be just pay everybody and then let them sort out what they do for themselves. Because we have this idea that's drilled into our heads that people want something for nothing, but as I say, they're very fact that people
嗯哼。中情局在阴暗处干了一些相当古怪肮脏的勾当，但我个人很高兴有他们在。你觉得呢，戴维？如果我们没有狗屁工作，数百万人的薪水从何而来？嗯，有很多方法可以解决这个问题。可能最简单的方法就是给每个人发钱，然后让他们自己决定用这些钱做什么。因为我们脑子里被灌输了一种观念，认为人们想要不劳而获，但正如我所说，那些……
who are actually paid to do nothing are so unhappy, shows that that's not really true. People really do want to have an effect on the world around them. I always give the example of prisons, obviously in America, they basically force people to work, but even where they don't, you know, they have really nice prisons. They use withdrawing your work privileges as a way of punishing you. That is to say, you know, given a choice between sitting around playing cards or watching TV all day and pressing shorts in the prison laundry room, you know, even these mostly rather anti-social people, you know, would actually rather work than just sit around. So people want to work.
实际上拿薪水却什么都不干的人又是如此痛苦，这表明事实并非如此。人们确实希望对他们周围的世界产生影响。我总是举监狱的例子，显然在美国，他们基本上迫使人们工作，但即使在不这样做的监狱里，你知道，他们的监狱条件非常好。他们将剥夺你的工作特权作为一种惩罚方式。也就是说，你知道，如果在整天坐着玩纸牌、看电视与在监狱洗衣房里熨短裤之间做出选择，你知道，即使是这些大多反社会的家伙，你知道，其实也更愿意工作而不是闲坐着。所以人们是想工作的。
So I kind of support universal basic income. I've kind of come around to the position that that's probably the best solution. If we just give people, you know, we say like, okay, all this technology, all these robots, you know, it's produced collectively by all of us. It's not like one person came up with that. That's a product of, you know,
所以我某种程度上支持全民基本收入。我渐渐转变为支持这种立场的态度，认为这可能是最好的解决方案。如果我们只是给人们发放资金，你知道，我们说，好吧，所有这些技术，所有这些机器人，你知道，这是我们所有人共同创造的。这可不是某个人自己想出来的。那是……
a center of ancestors doing hundreds of years of thinking and and laboring. So let's pay us all back for that work, you know. Let's give everybody a basic income and leave it up to you to decide what to do. To be sure, a universal basic income is a controversial idea. Also, while it would take care of essential needs, a basic income wouldn't buy people lots of dinners in fine restaurants or vacations in Cabo. David's underlying point though is that instead of aspiring for greater material wealth, we should all seek more leisure time. I know perfectly well that there's lots of societies, most societies where people work
历代祖先数百年的思考和劳动的产物。所以让我们为这项工作向所有人支付报酬吧。让我们给每个人一份基本收入，然后由你自己决定该做什么。可以肯定的是，全民基本收入是一个有争议的想法。此外，虽然它能满足基本需求，但基本收入并不能让人在高级餐厅享用大量晚餐或去卡波度假。不过，戴维的根本观点是，我们不应该渴望拥有更多的物质财富，而应该寻求更多的闲暇时间。我很清楚，有许多社会，大多数社会中的人们工作时间……
distinctly less than they do today. Probably the average oppressed medieval surf worked about half of what we work. But certainly people in other societies can be found to work two or three hours a day maximum. So what do they do? They come up with incredibly interesting things to do. You know, we'd all be sitting around in cafes, gossiping, and the gossip would get really interesting, you know, because people would have enough time to have lives. We just don't know what it's like to actually have a life anymore, a lot of us. If I didn't have to work and I still have money coming in, I would be in a
明显比主要社会少得多。一个受压迫的中世纪农奴的平均工作量可能只有我们工作量的一半左右。但可以肯定的是，在其他社会中，人们每天最多工作两三小时。那么他们都在做什么呢？他们想出了极其有趣的事情来做。你知道，我们都会坐在咖啡馆里闲聊，而且闲聊会变得非常有趣，你知道，因为人们会有足够的时间去过生活。我们中的许多人只是不知道真正拥有生活是什么感觉。如果我不需要工作，而且还有源源不断的收入，我就会去……
developing country in Africa, helping people learn and participate in the democratic process and get rid of leaders who don't support their interests. I'd love to be in like a cover band. I think that would be a lot of fun. Led Zeppelin, Black Sabbath, you know, those kind of genres. If I didn't have to work, I'd go to Asia. You know, I would ensure that those individuals that have substance use disorder were really
非洲的一个发展中国家，帮助人们学习并参与民主进程，摆脱那些不符合他们利益的领导人。我很乐意加入一个翻唱乐队。我觉得那会非常有趣。齐柏林飞艇、黑色安息日，你知道，就是那种类型的乐队。如果我不需要工作，我会去亚洲。你知道，我会确保那些患有物质使用障碍的个人真正能够……
taken care of on an equitable level. I mean, I like to go to the space. The space? Yeah. If I have money, I know if I can do anything. I love to see the London School of Economics. He studies theories of value and social constructs. He is the author of the book, Bullshit Jobs.
得到公平水平的照顾。我的意思是，我喜欢去太空。太空？是的。如果我有钱，我知道我能做任何事。我喜欢参观伦敦政治经济学院。他研究价值理论和社会结构。他是《狗屁工作》一书的作者。
David, thanks for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's been a real pleasure. This week's episode was produced by Aditya Bound Labudi with help from Parth Shah and Laura Koural. It was edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Raina Cohen and Thomas Liu. Special thanks to Dan Charles. Our run song here of this week is Samuel Alwin Mosley, a producer at the BBC. There are
戴维，谢谢你今天来到《隐藏大脑》。这真的是一次非常愉快的交谈。本周的节目由阿迪蒂亚·鲍恩·拉布迪（Aditya Bound Labudi）制作，帕特·沙阿（Parth Shah）和劳拉·库拉尔（Laura Koural）提供了帮助。节目由塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）编辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）和托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）。特别感谢丹·查尔斯（Dan Charles）。我们本周的片尾曲来自BBC制作人塞缪尔·阿尔温·莫斯利（Samuel Alwin Mosley）。有……
lots of logistical details that go into coordinating an interview, particularly when a guest is overseas. David Graber was in London when we spoke with him, and Samuel took care of all those little details to make sure the conversation went smoothly. Thank you, Samuel. If you've escaped from a bullshit job and have advice for listeners in a similar situation, share your story with us on social media, either by tagging us in the post or with a hashtag you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
许多后勤细节需要协调来安排一次采访，特别是当嘉宾身在海外时。我们与戴维·格雷伯交谈时，他正在伦敦，塞缪尔处理了所有这些小细节，以确保对话顺利进行。谢谢你，塞缪尔。如果你已经摆脱了一份狗屁工作，并且对处于类似境况的听众有什么建议，请在社交媒体上与我们分享你的故事，可以通过在帖子中标记我们，或使用话题标签。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。